there was never a dull moment on the set
of Indiana Jones and the dial of Destiny
like the time that Phoebe Waller Bridge
dressed up like Harrison Ford to scare
him and do you know what better than a
slap in the belly with a wet fish means
Phoebe learned the hard way this is
everything that went on behind the
scenes in the newest Indiana Jones movie
if this is the last time you'll see him
wearing Indies Fedora then Harrison's
going all out he did many of his own
stunts for the movie even though he was
bordering 80 at the time I'm having more
fun than I really should so don't tell
anybody like when he rode horseback
through Glasgow Scotland serving as the
set for New York City Harrison had a bit
of trouble getting off the horse
afterwards but when anyone tried to help
him he said quote leave me alone I'm an
old man getting off a horse and I want
it to look like that but it's also
really impressive that you were actually
still the person doing all that crazy
stuff but the stunt that Harrison
struggled the most with simply throwing
a punch at that's Mickelson's character
Harrison actually injured his shoulder
doing this delaying production by a
month it's gonna hurt but he's gonna do
it anyway luckily he still had some time
for some much needed fun there was a lot
of joking around on this set and
according to Phoebe Waller Bridge she
and Harrison were the worst for it at
one point Phoebe even tried to scare
Harrison by putting on a mask of his
face that had been made for his stunt
double and hiding in his trailer she
said that it actually worked quote even
though that actually is only represented
by him blinking three times and saying
get the hell out of my trailer Harrison
returned the favor 20 minutes later by
sneaking up on a Phoebe wearing a mask
of her face he even went so far as to
tie his shirt into a bow to match her
outfit which sounds better than a slap
in the belly with a wet fish have you
figured out what that means yet it means
things could be worse and it's a phrase
Harrison Ford is fond of saying which
caused Phoebe a bit of confusion on set
according to Harrison she asked him what
it meant when they were quote sitting on
a set that happened to have a lot of wet
fish and so he said he had the chance to
quote show her what a slap in the belly
with a wet fish is like luckily Harrison
was too much of a gentleman to make her
go through it and considering she
doesn't have the stunt training he does
that was probably for the best
Harrison's bare torso served as the
testing board Phoebe said I got the
biggest fish I could find and dragged it
over at that point according to Harrison
quote she whacked the stuffing out of me
but it was all okay he apparently loved
it and if you love our Channel just as
much we'd recommend taking this time to
subscribe what do you think Phoebe
struggled with most on set easily the
stunts I think the physical side of this
film was really surprising and exciting
you may in a way be able to feel what
Phoebe's saying when she describes
herself as a lanky gangly kind of
awkward physical person when she'd heard
that she'd gotten the role in and
Indiana Jones Phoebe immediately began
doing a lot of training for her big
stunt debut but when she told the
director what she was doing James
Mangold said quote I think it would be
funnier if you don't he told her it was
important that they were messy and
Phoebe said quote it was fun to mess
things up like the characters do still
even though it didn't have to be quite
as slick as Harrison Ford taking the
Indiana Jones costume home Phoebe still
needed to do the stunts well and she was
both surprised and excited by how
physical the role was you may be having
a hard time saying goodbye to Indiana
Jones but Harrison Ford is taking it
even harder occasionally uh feel
emotional I I'm not embarrassed by it
he's been so moved by the amount of
support these films have had and felt
like he was coming home by putting back
on that Fedora he felt like he knew the
character so well preparation was not
really necessary it makes us wonder if
Antonio Banderas feels the same about
Puss in Boots but did you know that
Harrison may even be taking the Fedora
home with him well you can't know
because you have no idea what I do in my
house it sounds like he and kalista
Flockhart his wife of 13 years have been
getting up to some fun with the costume
if I dress up in Indiana Jones clothes
and do certain things with my wife
that's not really anything to do with
you but let's try to keep it kid
friendly here it's the little things
that get us by Phoebe got along with
pretty much everyone on set although
she'd been nervous to meet big stars
like Harrison and Matt's she said quote
within 15 seconds it just felt like we
were a gay one of her favorite memories
from set comes to us from Antonio
Banderas well Antonio Banderas would do
the Puss in Boots impression whenever
you asked him Harrison didn't see what
the big deal was didn't help me much
but Phoebe definitely appreciated the
laugh still Harrison agreed that he'd
never seen actors quite so giving as
they were on this movie and apparently
it was Phoebe in particular that he had
to thank for being very present and
emotionally involved in the scene it's a
pure joy I had a lot of that in this
moment but if Phoebe was present then
Harrison was definitely going back to
the past with this role you never saw
anything like this in the original
movies Indiana Jones and the dial of
Destiny shows us flashbacks to Indy as a
young man which was accomplished using
AI assisted visual effects technology
that actually pulled Indiana Jones
expressions from the Lucas film library
in order to superimpose them over
Harrison's face in editing Harrison
explained quote it's my mouth and
present day eyes but they put it on my
face from 40 years ago something which
he said was absolutely amazing when
Phoebe saw Harrison performing these
flashback scenes she thought that he did
it with the same amount of youthful
energy that he had the first time around
I don't really know why they have to
change your face
can you imagine if they had decided to
go that route but Indy's face isn't the
only thing from the original movies
that's back this time do you remember
that good old-fashioned John Williams
score well he's back for this movie and
this time he's bringing a whole new
score I didn't know if John would do the
whole movie I only prayed James Mangold
got pretty lucky with him at first he
said I'll write some themes and then he
just couldn't stop writing all the music
to the movie but then again maybe his
involvement isn't that surprising
considering how much Jon loves the
franchise I have been fortunate enough
to have been associated with the films
over quite a long period of time even
though John had originally said that the
dial of Destiny would feature his final
film score he later went back on that
statement when he said quote if they do
an Indiana Jones 6 I'm on board it seems
he loves these movies just as much as we
are loving the costumes don't you just
love the period look in these costumes
Shawnette Renee Wilson even got to
collaborate with the movie's costume
department when it came to her look
which she said was inspired by the quote
1960s black exploitation era seanette's
mood board had been plastered with
pictures of Pam Greer Foxy Brown and
Cleopatra Jones stating that she wanted
to pay quote beautiful homage to all of
that it took the longest amount of time
for the crew to perfect her fro which
apparently had started out pretty small
but over time her dude just kept growing
and growing until Shawnette just said if
we're gonna make a statement just you
know go big or go home and that's what
we did we wonder if it was a bit of
advice she got from Phoebe at the time
johnette and Phoebe got to be great
friends on set Shawnette said quote I
think we really really connected going
on Lovely trips in Edinburgh together
before going on to call the pair of them
Glasgow gals till we die Phoebe was even
nice enough to read a pilot had written
and give her a few tips Shawnette said
that Phoebe was very complimentary and
just went through a bit of her process
but she also suggested that Shawnette
should quote write what scares you
shonette agreed going on to say because
that's what the real craft is taking
something personal and fictionalizing it
and making it something that's relatable
to everyone we're glad to hear that
Phoebe was able to give something to
seanette that she'll be able to take
into the future and who knows maybe
we'll be seeing that pilot make its way
to our screen someday as much as the
cast definitely worked hard on this
movie it's nice for us to see that they
still played hard too between practical
jokes and gangs on set which of these
behind the scenes details surprised you
the most and what are your thoughts on
the newest Indiana Jones movie make sure
to let us know down in the comments
section